اعلنوا جداول زمنيه لاكمال العمليه
السياسيه في السودان اثار الردود فعل
متباينه بين مؤيد ومعارض الكتله
الديمقراطيه وانرفضت المشاركه في الاجتماع
الذي دعت اليه الاليه الثلاثيه بالقصر
الرئاسي وهو الاجتماع الذي اعلنت فيه
معالم العمليه السياسيه وتكوين حكومه
يقودها مدنيون في ابريل القادم
الكتله الديمقراطيه قالت انها ستناهض
الاتفاق الجديد كما تم الاعلان حوله من
التواريخ نحن في حل عنها ولا نلتزم بهذه
التواريخ ولا تعنينا في شيء ايضا ان تشكلت
حكومه هي حكومه الذين شكلوها لا تعنينا او
سنعمل كذلك وقتها على مناهضه هذه الحكومه
وكانت الاطراف الموقعه عالاتفاق الايطالي
قد حددت سقفا زمنيا لتكون هياكل الفتره
الانتقاليه
واختارت لينه صياغه الاتفاق النهائي وليله
اخرى للتواصل مع الرافدين الانضمام
للعمليه السياسيه كل الاطراف يعني اتفقت
على مساله رئيسيه اننا كله انه نصل
الاتفاق النهائي يوم واحد
ابريل استشعارا منا يعني الاوضاع الموجوده
في البلاد
والرغبه الشعبيه الكبيره في انه يعني يوضح
حد
يعني الحاله الحاليه محللون يرون ان
الصراع بين الفرقي السودانيين هو صراع على
السلطه اكثر منه على قضايا التحول
الديمقراطي يصعب تنفيذ هذه الجداول لان
الامر في النهايه مرتبط بصراع على السلطه
وكيكه السلطه بين هذه الاطراف التي وقعت
التي لم توقف حتى الان
ويغشى كثيرون من ان الصراع حول السلطه دون
تقديم تنازلات حقيقيه ربما يقود البلاد
الى ما لا تحمد عقبه
القرارات بوضع جداول زمنيه لتكوين حكومه
مدنيه تشير الى ان التسويه قد لا تنتظر
الممانعين في الانضمام اليها وهو ما يضع
الوسطاء امام تحدي اثناء سعيهم الى توسيع
قاعده المشاركه قبل الاتفاق النهائي
الهادف لتحقيق استقرار سياسي الطاهر
المرضي الجزيره الخرطوم